AOC said on MSNBC to gensaki that what
Tucker Carlson is doing is incitement to
his incitement to violence in the
government should be involved they
should be regulating this or whatever
she's what they're doing is the typical
leftist weasel words where she's of
course implying that Tucker Carlson
should be arrested and charged but then
saying no of course I I mean they they
should stop hate speech or something and
it's like you accused took a cross out
of committing a felony incitement to
violence that is I'm pretty sure
defamation per se meaning it's so
egregious to accuse someone of
committing a crime that it's much much
easier to overcome the burdens in time V
Sullivan Tucker Crossing is probably
just Sue AOC outright for saying this I
hope he does because there are people
who really incite violence like Savannah
that's right yeah you know what no I I
really I really hope that he does though
because to be quite hon
EST you do continue to incite people to
violence we can look at the lgbtq
community antifa black lives matter the
list goes on and on